good
afternoon good evening good morning
wherever you are welcome welcome to at
Stockwood
so we'll wait just a few moments here as
everybody is getting their their sound
in their video and everything loaded and
if you are on live with us
um we would love to see your smiling
faces I would love to see your smiling
faces it just brightens my day to see so
many people
who are excited in
empowered to find information that can
help them and their selves
their families their communities just
create a healthy or healthier
environment
um with empowering options so we do
provide options that you're not going to
hear everywhere in fact very few places
where you hear this so we encourage you
to help us share this information
on asdoc live we have been going for
almost two and a half years and all of
those programs and replays are available
on askdoc
live.com that's ask doc
live.com all one word you can go there
and find all of our replays we've got
brief descriptions on the replays John
to mccollier our webmaster and our
technical Guru is really good about
getting those replays posted with some
enough information that if you do a
search on the website it'll come up with
those videos that will include
information about those symptoms so we
do try to stay away from medical
terminology but you know our body has
symptoms it's clues that it gives us to
let us know that hey there's something
going on and as Dr Wallach calls on red
warning lights so
with that being said welcome to ask doc
live my name is Rebecca Dix Kozak and I
will be your host for the next two hours
in providing it empowering information
that will benefit you on your health
Journey
whether you're here just for the
knowledge whether you're here to find
out what is going to be a best protocol
for you because we will be given some
protocols we will be taking questions so
if you have a question for uh Dr Wallach
make sure that you raise your virtual
hand here on the zoom if you're on live
with us so go to the zoom menu
reactions click raise hand now if you
were invited by somebody specific
and you want to get the protocol or
products that are mentioned within this
program make sure you get back with the
person that invited you to watch this
show they took the time and have a
vested interest in making sure that you
also get the information you need
because they want to keep you around
I there is absolutely no reason
we have to
be average or below average when it
comes to life expectancy and Longevity
and that's information that we're going
to be sharing with you today
so also if you're on live with us make
sure that you have that chat
Box open because our incredible co-hosts
will be putting information in that chat
to help you find more information about
what we are talking about today
so unfortunately if you're watching the
replay that chat's not available but
every Friday 8 A.M to 10 a.m Pacific
time we are here live on ass doc live
and we invite you to get your personal
invitation go to askdoglive.com and sign
up for our newsletter and that will get
you your invitation each week with the
link to Our askdoc Life program you can
also reply to that email if you have
questions that you would like to ask of
Dr Wallach about your personal condition
or that one the condition of somebody
that you love or care about and one of
our certified holistic health coaches
will be able to reply to your email and
make sure that you're getting the
information that is going to set your
health Journey on a more positive
trajectory how's that work all right
everybody
um I just again want to thank you all
for being here with us and the content
of this information is to provide
educational information only and it is
on the importance of nutrition and
supplementation
it was back in the 1930s that it was
determined by the U.S government that
our food supplies around our country
around our world are empty and void of
what the body needs to survive our soil
is depleted of minerals and plants
cannot create minerals without minerals
already being in the ground folks this
program will be sharing those
nutritional options that are available
to fill those gaps through
supplementation and a form that a body
can actually readily absorb now the
statements have not been evaluated by
the Food and Drug Administration the
products discussed are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease and again the information of
this Zoom is for informational purposes
if you are pregnant nursing or taking
medication please consult your health
care professional before starting on any
supplement program
now our good doctor Dr Joel Wallach has
been instrumental in suing that fine
establishment of the FDA with victories
nine times now these victories have led
to the additional vital nutrients added
to foods and allowing the distribution
of this information that has been proven
by science to be factual in the
essential need of the supplementation
against dis-ease
so we bring good news the genetic theory
if you have been told you have a genetic
condition well that genetic theory has
been proven to be incorrect through the
science of epigenetics which is the
study of how your own behaviors and
environment can cause changes that
affect the way those genes are expressed
and with epigenetics you are an
empowered individual and have more
control than you think over how your
body
thrives or survives in this health
Journey
so we invite you to feel the difference
with the options that are provided in
this program and
to guide us
we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of epigenetics who is
also the recipient of the 2011 claw
Schwartz commemorative medal the
lifetime achievement on natural medicine
and philanthropy philanthropy from the
United Nations
which was presented in 2015 fear to
guide us with the best options to obtain
or maintain
Optimal Health
Dr Joel Wallach Dr Wallach welcome to
askdoc live
too much well thank you so much for the
kind introduction and I'm very excited
today for a variety of reasons number
one of course we have so many of our
projects moving forward and some are
going to come to fruit very quickly
here's I'm very proud of all the
activities that you and your team have
done bring that to happen
and today also Veterans Day and I want
to thank our veterans of all you know of
our military disciplines the Army the
Navy the Marines the Air Force and so
forth
and um I spent more than 20 years in the
military I spent seven years
um in the Army at Fort Leonard Wood uh
in Central Missouri it was the 105 155
howitzer's artillery
and
um that was quite an experience
and then now let's see here uh I got
into the Air Force and I spent the rest
of the 20 years in the Air Force from
Elmendorf
um in Alaska Anchorage Alaska and I
didn't spend all my time in aggregious I
was going to probably about I'd say
about 30 different countries
um around the world and also so many
different I think all the continents I
went to all the continents through the
Air Force and
um my my responsibilities were quite
wide everything from taking care of the
guard dogs because I'm a veterinarian
and a physician but also dealing with
the
um
um food supply coming in making sure
that was good uh for our
members of the military but also weapons
I was also involved with receiving
weapons and arming them and making sure
they work properly and didn't blow our
own people up and all that kind of stuff
so I covered quite a bit of stuff in the
military of course I'm wearing proudly
my um Veterans of the Air Force had here
um
and so I just want to thank all of our
veterans I want to invite them to join
us they have so much
talent and training and experience in
communicating and observing and
transmitting information and if they
could apply that they could have
wonderful home-based businesses and for
their families and so forth and help put
their kids through college and pay off
their bills and and so forth especially
there's so many people being laid off
and businesses closing and so forth
because of the pandemic stuff and and so
on so I do especially today on Veterans
Day inviting all of our veterans of
every
um one of the military divisions to join
us okay and they can go to well what
what numbers would you give out for that
Rebecca well just to start Dr Wallach if
they were invited to this program by
somebody specific get back with the
person invited them to this program
absolutely if you were not invited to
this program by anybody specific you can
go to ask live.com and use the contact
us and let us know that you're
interested in more information but Dr
Wallach I want to take a minute to thank
you for your service because not only
did you have service in the Air Force
but you also had service in the army
and that's a lot of time that's been
dedicated to supporting our country and
its safety and vitality so thank you so
much Dr Wallach on Veterans Day for your
service well thank you thank you thank
you it was a learning experience
a 20-year period and so
uh I'm very very uh proud I think
there's a song I'm proud to be an
American
I'm proud to be an American yeah at
least I know I'm free there you go yes I
love that song yeah okay and so uh it's
still true and we have so much good to
do for not only America but for the
world and so let's get it on and of
course the the piece you're talking
about
um were were the U.S Senate came in was
1936 U.S Senate document 264. they came
out and said our farm soils no longer
have sufficient minerals in them to
support
healthy human life
and and doctors are still saying oh just
eat well you get everything you need
that's absolutely positively not true so
I urge you I urge you and of course I
was handing out obituaries of doctors at
meetings uh you know doctors they died
35 well they're running a marathon or
they'd die at 42 well they're doing the
surgery and
um the average lifespan of emergency
room doctors in America is 58. it
doesn't make sense right and so I was at
a meeting I forget where it was I think
it was in Texas and then a medical
doctor big guy comes up to me during the
meeting right and says interestingly
speaking and he comes up to me and he
says okay well I can find the whole
audience they're all cringing out there
they don't know what's going to happen
and he says uh okay well like why are
you giving out all these obituaries of
doctors what's going on here and I just
sat out of my mouth and I had never
thought of it before I just said only
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and so I I came
up with that and
um we sold 90 million of those audiocast
sets 90 million okay before the books
were printed and so we're getting the
word out there we need to deal with that
and so let's go now with that said
we have some very basic things we have
uh some health stuff that has to do with
nutrition okay we have a book and a CD
and a DVD set a three-piece set book CD
and DVD it's called the the um the truth
about nutrition and I want everybody to
get this set okay you buy 10 sets you
get a big discount
all right
and Dr Wallach as a homeschooling mom
I love this set
to include in our health education
program
so my son and I have started reading
through this and it's going through the
basics and teaching about the health and
the importance of nutrition
so if you are a homeschooling family or
grandparents of a homeschooling family
this would be a fabulous fabulous
Christmas gift because Christmas is
coming fast
um in helping to provide additional
information that will help your kids
your grandkids your great-grandkids have
healthier life going farther into life
and enjoying life Dr Wallach because I
know I used to not look forward to
getting gold
and now I have no reservation about
getting old I love it
well you just have to get used to being
old for for 400 years
only if the good Lord wants me to be
here that long Dr Wallach so
okay and then of course we have
immortality it's also another book in
the story but I'm going to get to that
in a minute but a very important book in
the story uh is Hell's Kitchen it goes
from the transition from wood and pole
as fuel were used as ashes which are 98
minerals and two or three percent carbon
of the wood ashes and coal ashes for
fertilizer and spices put in our food
we've got minerals that way well in
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 we went to
electricity with Thomas Edison and
suddenly now are a source of a minerals
we've had for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years went away and
doctors said oh just eat well you get
everything you need that's absolutely
positively not true if I urge everybody
also to get the book rare Earth's
Adventures it's a big one as well you
got okay rarest Ventures chapters 10 and
11 start at page 272. it'll tell you how
to collect your hair how to put it in an
envelope or to send it don't forget to
put the check in there because they
won't do the test without the check and
you'll find out what your status is of
your nutritional minerals you'll find
out what your status is of toxic metals
like lead and mercury and
all those these things uh that there's
probably about 25 different toxic metals
and so forth and there's sick there's 60
right 60 nutritional minerals XD
essential nutritional minerals yes it's
essential nutrition and Trace
yeah and so and then immortality this is
a five-year study that we actually spent
going around the world and visiting uh
there you go visiting
um
long-lived cultures and finding out what
they proactively did proactively avoided
and what they proactively did to what
they did to
live to be 120 and 140 and 160. and you
know again our emergency room doctors in
America their life expectancy is 58 our
life expectancy uh in America
um for the average American is um 75 to
79 depending on whose numbers you look
at and so we have a problem here so
what's going on well it's what we're
eating it's what we're not eating it's
what nutrients we're not getting and so
you had to be responsible for all this
and that's why we have 21 best-selling
books and sets we have four more coming
out one of which Rebecca and her team
have been very very
um prominent in the Wallach Revolution
that's coming out here pretty soon now
I'm very excited about that
now because it's symbolic Story from
beginning to
now because the end is about 600 years
away I believe there you go the Warlock
Revolution
and the complete version is at the
printer as we speak okay so thank you
thank you thank you Becca and your team
and um
they also want to remind everybody that
we have toxic things we have to really
be aware of and most of them we've been
introduced to by doctors and and people
who are well-meaning uh things like
wheat bread around oats they have gluten
in them they destroy your small
intestines so you cannot efficiently
absorb nutrients and then there's
buckwheat now buckwheat of course you
find in pancakes in sort of a cereal
kind of like a
um uh oatmeal cereal made out of out of
Buckwheat and then of course we had also
uh let's see here the buckwheat noodles
all right and buckwheat
um just like meatball Ryan oats have
gluten in them buckwheat has phagopyries
in them and the phagopyries inflame your
blood vessels and in your organic
tissues and glands and everything and
you wind up with a disease called lupus
erythema okay get all these rashes on
your face and everything and you get gut
issues and so people who eat gluten and
buckwheat oh my gosh you are in deep due
to deep trouble okay so uh lupus
um fibromyalgia
rheumatoid arthritis cereal bowel
syndrome uh Crohn's disease celiac
disease diverticulitis metabolic
syndrome which is obesity diabetes and
high blood pressure and then there's
central nervous system demyelization
which is things like Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease MS multiple
sclerosis gambarre syndrome all of these
are are caused by the white matter of
the brain the myelin going away makes up
25 percent of the brain weight 25
percent of your spinal cord weight is
cholesterol do not take cholesterol
lowering drugs and eat three eggs twice
a day as an adult make sure your kids
are getting eggs make sure if the
mother's breastfeeding she's eating age
three times a day maybe even three three
times a day and make sure that the
baby's getting one meal a day are kids
tardy and make sure the mother is not
eating gluten and not eating buckwheat
because that will interfere with the
nutrition getting into the breastfed
baby okay so all this stuff is so
important
um
I just can't uh I I just get breathless
when I think about it and then for
energy rather than soft drink
oh can't hear you
okay I do want to interrupt you since
you were on the buckwheat topic
okay
you have to speak up
since you're on the buckwheat topic Dr
Wallach I do want to interrupt you for
just a minute because when you are
looking up buckwheat and gluten-free
foods it is actually something that
comes up as being beneficial they don't
talk about
this chemical that's toxic within the
body that causes severe skin rashes and
if it's on the outside it's on the
inside as well and that is something
that I experienced and didn't realize it
because I thought I was doing right by
using buckwheat as an alternative and in
many countries when I looked up what
foods contain buckwheat
I mean there's a list of things that
unless you are specifically looking at
the label you would not know that there
was buckwheat in that food
so really really look at labels you
don't want wheat barley Rye oats
or buckwheat
on those labels when as especially not
in the first five ingredients
I mean not at all but still they're
usually within the first couple
ingredients so it doesn't take much to
read labels and find these yeah it's
like saying don't shoot yourself in the
head with a 45 it's safe to shoot
yourself in the head with a 22. no you
don't want any
foreign
well I'm gonna I'm gonna say shoot
yourself in the foot it's still gonna
hurt whether it's a 45 or a 22. it's
still going to hurt really bad
and can cause later issues so let's just
be proactive in making sure that we take
those things out of our diets now so
that we're not being affected now or in
the future
so let's go to energy now Dr Wallach
thanks for letting me interrupt okay
well it was good stuff
yeah good stuff and so energy of course
we want to talk about a rebound
um and of course you take your 90
essential nutrients and this is what our
hair analysis where we talked about that
with the book Rare Earth adventures and
you need the nutrients for your body to
make energy repair itself do all that
kind of stuff and then you need the raw
materials and
um we have an energy drink okay it's in
a can a canister and sticks it has 75
minerals in it 75 minerals 25 vitamins
amino acids there's 30 sticks in a box
you can take two or three of these in
your pocket during the day you know they
only they don't even weigh an ounce okay
and it's one of those things where you
can either staple them to or it's kind
of dangerous because you want to be
puncturing this with a Staples so I like
to Scotch tape these to your business
cards and hand out your business card
and say hey we're looking for people who
want to get our our energy drink out
there plus our other information okay
for over
um let's see here 900 different diseases
all right 600 different diseases okay we
need
people to get that and then of course we
have the canister which has 36 servings
in there there's a scoop in here and you
can put one scoop so 36 times into a
bottle of water and make your your
rebound that way okay
and then also when I'm at home
um we I we use the cans a rebound uh
they're 12 ounce cans there's 12 of them
in a case and they have these little pop
tops and
um they have carbonation in them that's
kind of a No-No so what I do is I pop
the tops into these cans before I go to
bed at night put in the refrigerator
they off gas the carbonation during the
night time they're flat all the bubbly
is gone in the morning I drink one with
breakfast I'll drink the second one with
my lunch or maybe an hour or two after
lunch depending on my schedule what I'm
going to be expanding the energy here
not and so this is where we get the
energy in every tissue in your body
including your brain needs energy right
and
here's where I like
um the book and the CD it's on your head
it's on your head there's 12 pairs of
cranial nerves your spinal cord all of
which are made in the brain and when you
get osteoporosis of the skull
what happens is
um
the
um the skull squeezes one or more of
these cranial nerves squeezes spinal
cord and there's 37 different diseases
you can get
if you have osteoporosis of the skull
everything you know from dental problems
dental problems to hearing problems and
loss of the sense of smell you can't
taste anything balance problems vertigo
blindness hearing problems dizziness all
this kind of stuff and
um south of the skull sciatica all the
stuff going on in all your joints and
everything hammer toes
um trigger fingers all these things are
caused by osteoporosis and it's called
squeezing the spinal cord and so this is
so important and I I find it kind of
interesting the doctors approach say oh
don't do what wallic says I'll use all
those vitamins and minerals let us cut
your leg off and give you an artificial
leg oh let us cut your joints out and
let's give you an artificial hip hip
replay double hip replacement let's give
you a double knee replacement
I want to try my stuff first for 90 days
and see if we can't rebuild your hips we
can't we'll be we'll rebuild your knees
we'll rebuild your disc we'll rebuild
your vertebrae
and you won't need to have surgery
see your doctor pays for his kids
tuition by doing the knee Replacements
and the hip replacements and giving you
artificial limbs that's how he sends
their kids to college okay
tried for 90 days our way and you know
it's one of those things you're going to
spend about you know 20 bucks a day or
something like that and rebuild
everything
and
it's one of those things where you're
way ahead of the game because there's no
risk of anesthesia problems
and um one of the ones that really loves
the 10th cranial nerve being squeezed
you get one of the many things that
happens when you have a tense trailer
being squeeze is afib atrial
fibrillation doctors want to anesthetize
you put you on a surgery table cut your
chest open take your heart out and do
what's called an ablation they take a
hot Branding Iron and touch it all over
the heart looking for the place that's
making your heart go wacko but that's
not possible because it's not a heart
issue it's a skull the tense cranial are
being squeezed causing The Irregular
Heartbeat it's not a heart problem it's
actually approach to the skull I mean
you have afib don't let them do ablation
it has the highest percentage of deaths
and other terrible things that go wrong
with ablation it's a very very bad
treatment don't volunteer for that one
okay and so with all that said
um I just get very very excited about
our days here and I'm looking
at the time here okay and so I'm gonna
put this back to you because I can go on
and on and on and on forever here but if
I don't know how many callers we have so
I'll throw it to you back and then you
can choose where we're going all right
Dr Wallach thank you so much for that
information I think everybody else can
hear me you dropped one so go ahead and
put the other one in your ear too and
then you'll be able to hear me in stereo
um but we do we want to make sure that
you can hear because we do have callers
and people with their hand raised and we
thank you all for being here with us on
ass doc live and remind you that if you
were invited by somebody specific make
sure that you get back with them and let
them know how much you appreciate them
sharing this information with you today
can you hear me better now Dr Wallach
yes thank you
I love your humor Dr Wallach thank you
well Dr Wallach let's get to the first
hand that is uh and Susan
looks like Susan and a friend here are
here with us Dr Wallach Susan go ahead
you were let me make sure you can unmute
there we go
you're on live with Dr Wallach so what's
going on Susan
hi Doug Wallach it's a pleasure to meet
you we're from Meadow Lake Saskatchewan
oh okay Canada that's right the cold
country
um Reynold has recently been diagnosed
with Parkinson's
he's 58 about 200 pounds
220 I heard that okay
does um do you have any other issues
such as high blood pressure diabetes
no
okay do you have any ringing in the ears
any tinnitus bringing in the ears
the only symptoms I have are numbness in
my hand my right hand
okay
they can't pick up anything really small
if I try it's kind of like your nerve is
being stopped okay but you do have
Tremors that go along with Parkinson's
no
okay
um do you have memory problems
yes okay
uh do you have vision problems
um what about your sense or taste have
you launched your sense of taste no I
still have that sense of taste and sense
of humor okay good what about sense of
smell
but not too strong okay
all right yeah yeah it may since you
don't have Tremors which is classic for
Parkinson's
um you may actually have osteoporosis as
a skull are you slowly losing vision
well my vision is kind of hard to get
glasses because it changes so rapidly
it's gotten poorer since I gotten my
last pair okay okay yeah it could be
this old squeezing the optic nerve or
any optic nerve atrophy and uh that's
caused by osteoporosis of the skull and
um do you have anything going on let's
see here's one how many times a night
you wake up to urinate once three times
five times
a couple of times okay drink water okay
two three maybe
yeah
okay yeah you have actually a process go
that's what's causing you to get up at
night to urinate
um that's also what's causing you to
slowly be losing your vision on a
rapidly scale because the skull is
squeezing the optic nerve can cause
numbness
um in your hand
um by squeezing the spinal cord and one
of the branches of the spinal cord go to
your arm okay and that's good and of
course getting up at night to urinate
the skull is squeezing the spinal cord
and the spinal cord is telling your
urinary bladder to urinate and so that's
why all this is going on now what about
dental problems how many Dentures or or
implants or anything like that no just
fillings okay all right
um
let's see here any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea
um maybe a little more constipation
since I've been on the vitamins okay
all right
and so you're already taking stuff but
I'm just for our viewers and listeners
also and you're in the military
no just a carpenter okay you're a
carpenter okay well
and see I Think Jesus was a carpenter
yeah he was maybe even maybe nine
okay okay so
um
I want you to get rid of all the bad
foods and again this is for all of our
listeners too
um everybody's got to give all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed Meats
of any kind no no
um
wheat bread oats uh no gluten uh no
buckwheats absolutely no
um the processed Meats uh of any kind
um and then no sugar of course no carbon
or drinks
they need to go because they actually
neutralize stomach acid so you can't
absorb minerals and digest food and that
kind of thing and then at 220 pounds
ideally it would take two healthy brain
and heart packs for months two healthy
brain and heart capture photos
everything twice a day then you need two
bottles a month for MSM take three of
breakfast three at lunch three dinner
time and they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a very bone makes bone
itself including the skull okay then you
need two of our canisters of collagen
peptides so you can take a scoop of that
with your morning breakfast and drink
and a scoop of that with your evening
drink
then I also want you to have the Beyond
Osteo FX a scuba that with their morning
drinks whether you're eating drink then
vitamin D3 three of those even in
California because most people you know
don't get in their bathing suit and sit
out in the sun for two hours a day like
kids do and it's almost adults when they
go around watching the kids out in the
sun they're sitting in the shade and so
you need to take your vitamin D3 take
three of those twice maybe two bottles a
month and then I also want you to take
because you have stuff going on upstairs
here I want you to take three eggs twice
a day three eggs twice a day with soft
yolks you need that cholesterol don't
forget don't take any cholesterol
lowering drugs you do need three eggs
twice a day with soft yolks soft boiled
soft poached and I also uh want you to
see here uh what else let's let's go
with that
um
oh synaptive I do need to take synaptic
take three of those twice a day there's
two bottles a month and that's going to
give your brain what it likes also the
brain wants to be happy and there's
three different divisions of nutrients
the brain needs and the synaptive have
um contributions each of those three
groups okay call us every couple weeks
because you're going to have a great
story
and um
uh we we deal a lot with Canada
we do we deal a lot with Canada and so
there you know there are next door
neighbor and um we love Canadians and uh
we
um I used to go up there like almost
every week in Canada but because of this
covid thing and all the stuff you had to
go through through the Border it looks
like things are kind of on one hand
getting better and some places getting
worse so we'll see but we do a lot of
zooms that the Canadians are involved in
so you might want to check that out
okay so let's see here uh
I guess right
over to you Becca thank you Susan and
Reynold and I know that you're in good
hands with the coach that you have so
um make sure you get back with her if
you have any questions and she can get
in contact with me if she has any
questions but she is very knowledgeable
in the products and protocol that Dr
Wallach has recommended for you
now next Dr Wallach I would like to go
to
um a chat question that was posted by
Yvonne and Yvonne has a client she has
is female 57 years old
five foot five
140 pounds
no medications
no diagnosis on the brain
or Noah diagnoses of anything she's
currently on the brain and heart pack
and has been for about a year no gluten
in the house she's compliant on the bad
foods list no animals and last year she
had several tiny red blood spots raised
up on her trunk so I think it's
there's a couple different terms for
those
um
and she wants to know and so it's on the
trunk of her body and on her neck
um occasionally
yeah okay and these yes these come along
because of a breakdown of the uh walls
of the little blood vessels in the skin
the same things are happening in her
lungs in her intestines because you know
it's surgery or autopsy when you open up
the intestines you see these same little
red bumps kind of like half the size of
a pea kind of thing and um they're
bright and red and shiny look like a
little Berry like a little cranberry
okay yeah and these we used to call them
blood blisters when I was a kid okay
um and they're caused by the deficiency
of this the stuff that can which I say
supports the maintenance of connective
tissue whether it's in the skin or the
walls of the intestine or the lungs or
the brain covering okay the meninges of
the brain uh they can be found anywhere
because there's a connective tissue so
what I would make sure that she's adding
to her program uh she's been using it
she may have to increase the
quantity because that wanted her to take
the collagen peptides and her body
weight she can take two canisters a
month to take a Scoopa that was a
breakfast drinks over their evening
drink she needs the
um let's see here I also want her to
have the MSM take two bottles a month to
take three breakfast right laundry
dinner time and that'll be very very
important
to deal with the skin the walls of
arteries and stuff like that and veins
and capillaries is where this is the
pathology is taking place and it's kind
of a literally a red warning light
because what's going on in the skin is
going on in the brain going on in the
eyes going on in the intestines going on
in the heart valves and going on in the
lungs liver and glands all over the
place and so we need to get these
supporting
nutrients in also I like the
um let's see here let's go with the
Beyond Osseo I said that let's go with
the
um ultimate daily classic Let's Go
ultimate daily classic uh two bottles a
month per month ultimate daily classic
take three twice a day and they're going
to support healthy blood flow okay
through blocked capillaries and arteries
and veins but also
um uh supports uh the the walls of the
arteries and veins so that they don't
get thickened and cause problems and
flow problems and so forth and sometimes
these little red spots will get better
and go away
you know you wake up one morning and uh
what's happened is the connective tissue
gets stronger and that little blister
flattens out and goes back into the skin
and you don't see it anymore it doesn't
pop and bleed but it'll just go back
into the skin okay so that's what you're
looking for okay
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach I
appreciate that and
Tony wants to know about cholesterol how
do I raise my HDL cholesterol because
right now Tony's cholesterol is at 34.
and I also heard that olives are good
for that but not I'm going to just add
in here not olive oil right Dr Wallach
not olive oil got to stay away from
uh canned and bottled olives
okay because who knows how long they've
been sitting on the shelf
three months three years you don't know
well Dr Wallach I personally know that
eating an olive tree right or eating an
olive right off the tree
is not very smart
they have to go through a brine process
so what I was thinking of let's focus on
the other foods that help to raise good
cholesterol
eggs
what else
um red meat
red meat and okay so let's talk about
red meat Dr Wallach do we have to trim
all the fat off of it no you want the
fat that's where the cholesterol is at
okay
um and of course red meat chicken fish
um all of these animal muscle products
okay have cholesterol in them and you
want the fat
you don't want to peel the fat off a
chicken breast and say you don't appeal
the skin and the fat off and throw in
the garbage or give it to the dog the
dog will be smiling all the way you know
yeah out to see all all the boys and
girls is that a healthier brain than you
that's correct let alone the hormones
that are being fed there's a good
cholesterol so all right so Tony I hope
that helps in in some options to help
raise the good cholesterol and Fry
anything don't fry anything because if
you fry good stuff it turns into being
bad stuff
that's right because it's converting
those molecules it's making things
crispy you don't want things crispy
um I know in the past somebody has asked
me well how how can I eat a baked potato
well yes steam it
you can still get the same goodness on
the inside without making that skin
crispy you just steam it and then mash
it orbit eat it baked and put butter on
and add butter yes and Himalayan salt
so
um Dr wallig as we're talking about salt
yep we got the seasoned salt so the
seasoned salt actually has sea salt from
Australia in it
that's right Australia New Zealand right
and uh it has
um
top cooked seasoning in there okay and
the piece that a lot of people don't
like uh from the Himalayan salt we have
we have pepper and black pepper and some
people are allergic to black pepper they
don't like black pepper but I I like the
the
um I I like the
um
so the seasoned salt actually has white
pepper yes and I personally know that
there is a difference in how my body
reacts to white pepper and black pepper
because I cannot have black pepper but I
can do the seasoned salt with the white
pepper so there you go
don't quite understand that but hey
that's what works
into your body
oh well and let's talk about salt Dr
Wallach so table salt they are stripping
all those minerals out away from the
sodium chloride that's correct now
um you have to appreciate back the first
supplements ever sold
was salt people on the east coast of all
the are not only the East Coast but the
coast all these continents that are
surrounded by oceans uh they would take
the the sea water and boil it and they
would get this salt and it had all the
trace minerals that were in the oceans
in the gulf and so forth and they would
go Inland and sell it for great amounts
of money okay because they could have
people with gliders you know big big
thyroids the size of cantaloupe and they
would get on that sea salt and within
weeks that glider would go away
and so it's like magic and so everybody
got into having salt and then you had
clever people saying well it's too much
work to do this and the other and so
they they would take all the minerals
out and just leave sodium chloride and
then it would add back a few things but
um and they weren't getting all the
results that they would get when they
had sea salt with all those other trace
minerals in there from the ocean and so
that's why we went with
um it's appreciate when they used to say
people are the salt of the earth that's
because salt was one of the greatest
things that ever happened to humanity it
was a proactive conscious way of getting
nutrients into people okay and getting
rid of disease they could see they could
see that glider going away
they had people who just couldn't
couldn't get out and work they're just
so exhausted but then they salt their
food they're they're okay
um they could digest their food because
you need to make hydrochloric acid you
have cheese cells in the walls of your
stomach to take salt and turn the salt
into Hydrochloric stomach acid okay
anybody who thinks you don't need salt
oh you should eat your food you get
plenty no don't don't think that way
okay and that's why we we came up with
the Himalayan salt and the seasoned salt
right now we just have on stock season
salt and we're in the process of getting
a Himalayan salt back but right now we
do have a warehouse full of the seasons
salt
but I have you know when we see when
these things are in you know I buy 10
canisters of these things and so I still
have three or four canisters of the
Himalayan salt left and I use that at
the kitchen table for myself and then
the seasoned salts uh I put out here
this show you know because I know we
have this immediately available
well let's talk a little bit more about
digestion Dr Wallach and the importance
of supporting the digestion
um the salt mineral full of minerals is
important for that
um because Angelica has a customer
that's on the 90 essential nutrients
it's been diagnosed with diabetes like
she's having vomiting and diarrhea the
doctor is just recommending Imodium and
gravel I'm not sure what that is
um so the client has decided to stay
away from food and she's lowering doses
of everything so we want to make sure
that she is salting her food so that the
food is actually being broken down in a
the right acidic environment of the
digestive system right correct but we
also have a couple other products that
can help in digestion
yeah I I I I like the um let's see here
um we have all kinds of uh enzymes I I
like our health let's see here our
digestive ultimate enzymes ultimate
enzymes that's a good place to start
ultimate enzymes okay and
um you can take uh say
um two of those say five to ten minutes
for each meal a couple ounces of water
the ultimate enzymes
and and
um and then you want to also use if you
have the Himalayan salt if you don't you
want to use a seasoned salt because it
has the
the minerals from the oceans around
Australia around New Zealand around the
United States around Hawaii okay and so
we have all this stuff and it's the
cheapest doctor you can get
is salt
okay yeah it does it does do a lot when
it comes to digestion and food and if
our food's not being broken down we're
not getting the nutrients even out of
the food even if there's limited
nutrients there
but one thing that I like Dr Wallach in
between Foods especially if I've had
like a really big meal and I'm just
feeling
you know not so great digest effects
is amazing
at being able to help relieve that
bloatedness and and just that ich feel
and then I also like the root beer belly
and sometimes that's just dessert it
tastes so good forget about dessert you
just take some Root Beer Belly helps to
break down the food that you've already
eaten it gives some pre and probiotics
in there also
um to help create a great import the
root beer belly was designed for kids to
get it into kids okay and it does taste
like root beer yeah so yeah and Heather
one of our co-hosts she loves Root Beer
Belly after having
after having a gastro surgery that went
bad root beer belly is one of her best
friends yeah so and so you know if you
have any burping belching bloating gas
coming out the other end that kind of
stuff give it a shot you can't go wrong
and give you know do the root beer belly
that's in addition to all the other
stuff you can't stop the other stuff
just to do with your belly it's an adult
no
so most definitely but it all starts
with the foundation Dr Wallach and that
is the 90 essential nutrients 60
uh minerals That's essential in trace
minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino acids
three essential fatty acids and if you
add it all up it's actually 91 but let's
just say 90 essential nutrients
and that's a foundation a foundation
that you can take each and every day and
not have to worry about what you're
getting in your food I mean yes we want
to eat healthy you cannot out supplement
a bad lousy diet I have many people that
have thought that and it just doesn't
work as well for them so I highly
encourage you to adopt the Good Foods
bad foods list if you do not have a copy
of the Good Foods or bad foods list and
you're on with us in Zoom check the chat
our co-host of including the link to
that good foods bad foods list in the
chat it is also found on our website at
askdoclive.com you can do a search there
for the good foods bad foods list and
that goes through
all of the things that you want to stay
away
from but most importantly the things
that you want to add to your diet I
don't know that okay you're gonna
correct me on that one I know you are
the most important thing is to stay away
from the bad foods but for me you have
to do both
when you tell me I can't have something
I need an alternative what's more
important oxygen or water you need them
both
you need them both that's right that's
right
so I love the fact that there are
alternatives that are offered there with
the good food so you don't have to feel
like you are being deprived of anything
because I mean there's a lot of good
stuff that we can eat
um but
as in that document stated in night with
a 1936 Dr Wallach
1976. our food does not have the
nutrition that it used to and think
about 1936 that was almost 90 years ago
was it nine yeah almost 90 years ago and
we've been continually farming the land
depleting it even further
and primarily what farmers put in large
um Fields is NPK nitrogen phosphorus
potassium because that'll give him
maximum growth in terms of tons in
bushels per acre is where he makes his
money and then when he makes some feed
for his pigs and his horses and his cows
and sheep out of that he'll add vitamins
and minerals to it
for them but you're getting the corn and
the wheat and all buck wheat and all the
bad stuff with just three nutrients in
them uh and all the bad stuff that goes
along with it and so that it's a very
bad situation
so basically we're getting the filler
and a little bit of nutrition unless
we're intentionally giving our body that
nutrition right yep
and the previous person we were talking
about had the diabetes don't forget the
sweeties
and the sweeties absolutely because that
gives the nutrients that important to
help to con
they're not important they're essential
essential essential they're essential
because
type 2 diabetes makes up 98 of the
diabetic population and it's 100 a
nutritional deficiency
it is not genetic it's not autoimmune
it's not anything else it's just a
nutritional efficiency of two elements
which one is it which one is it well you
get the program you'll see you get the
book you'll see and the reason why we
don't tell people because they they run
to the store and they'll buy that one
nutrient out of the 90 they're 90 short
or 89 sharp depending on what number
system you use
there's shark everything else and then
they die from something else well yeah
they did what you said they died okay
well we look at the body as a whole Dr
Wallach that's right
because
one piece does not function unless
everything else is functioning properly
also that's correct
so we have to feed the body how do you
spell when you see the body's a whole
how do you spell that
it's
w-h-o-l-e okay otherwise it's a whole
missing
and we don't want any holes in our body
especially not in our bones and in our
hearts and all that good stuff we want
to be solid and able to function as we
were designed to do well Dr Wallach
we're so close to the top of the hour
why don't we go ahead and take a quick
little break here on askdoc live
everybody don't go away because we will
be right back and
I want to remind you
get back with the person that invited
you to this program we do hope that this
program is offering information
that is getting you thinking about what
you're putting in your mouth because as
epigenetic States
what we put in our mouths and what we
have in our environment actually is what
influences how our genes are expressed
now if your grandparents had diabetes
and arthritis and all those things and
their grandparents did it's not because
it's genetic what has been handed down
is a way of eating
and with a continued depletion of soil
and
where our food is being grown
and the food it is being fed to are meat
supplies
it's continually
breaking down
and we want to make sure and be
intentional
in knowing that what we're putting into
our bodies is beneficial for our bodies
supporting ourselves and our body on a
whole we will be right back on massdoc
life get up and stretch hydrate take
deep breaths so that you're getting your
oxygen so that you're getting your water
because you need both and we'll see in
just a minute
all right and I am back let's see if Dr
Wallach is back yet
so everybody thank you for joining us
here on ass doc live my name is Becca
dukes krozak and I am the host of this
program have been since we started back
in July of 2020 and it is my honor to be
able to host this program now I have
been
really I've been blessed in my own
health Journey where I had tried
everything and
I heard Dr Wallach on a radio program as
many of our listeners have in many of
our subscribers in our newsletter have
heard Dr Wallach on coast to coast and
I'm like oh that just sounds too easy
but you know what I have tried
everything
so
why not why not
I so I gave
Dr Wallach 90 days as he suggested and
it has changed my life so not only will
have I been able to get rid of all of my
Pharmaceuticals and all of my conditions
that I had been dealing with even since
I was eight years old
I I feel great
and I love the fact that I am able to
age and and I feel like I'm aging
backwards and Dr Wallach if you are
there go ahead and unmute yourself and
you can click the okay to start your
video
there we go we got the ear pieces in I
think we're ready to get back started
okay can you hear me now yes we can hear
you fine I can even see you doc
yeah
so I see you too
good so let's go back to the Salt
because Jenny has a question okay she
says does that mean that sea salt is
good for people with thyroid issues so I
don't know if that's just thyroid issues
or
I mean all of us that have thyroids and
haven't had it removed well thyroid
gland requires all 90 essential
nutrients but there's one so you have to
appreciate that all our tissues require
90 essential nutrients but every organ
has what we call Secret Sauce as it
needs and one of the secret sauces that
the thyroid needs a lot of is iodine
yeah
okay I've made every little school kid
knows that I don't
but that's if you just take iodine but
none of the other 89 you're dead
well Dr Wallach school kids these days
they're not taught that and that's one
reason why I love this as part of my
curriculum
yeah it's the set the book the CD the
DVD yep yep absolutely so there's a book
DVD and a CD
and
so iodine is found in sea salt yes but
we also have a couple different versions
through youngevity that offers the
iodine we have the ultimate iodine and
liquid drops so if you feel that you
need additional iodine in your diet we
have that get back with the person that
invited you to this program and ask them
about the iodine products if you were
not invited to this program by anybody
specific
on our website askdoc live we do have a
store that you can click on the store
and get information at Dr Wallach you
just moved your camera
I'm sorry
you're fine are we okay um
yeah
there we go yeah okay I'm dragging a
book and the foot of the of the camera
sticks out about four inches and I
didn't see it I'm hitting that foot
sorry I you know what I'm so proud of
you for just
grabbing on to the technology and being
open
to do it
because not many people are when they
get in this habit of doing things and
especially when they've been on the road
for years
giving in present in-person
presentations for uh well it's not just
years 30 years decades yeah that's right
and here you are in your office in front
of a computer
and still going strong so I commend you
for even being a young 83 for grasping
onto technology and thank you so much
you're a good coach
well I'm trying I'm trying
as we have many good coaches here
available
um to help people find the right
products the right approach to their
health Journey also so I have another
question here and Angelica wants to know
hydration and elderly
what would you recommend for the best
hydration
um
but also for helping to build white
blood cells because she has a client
that has a low y
cell content
like skills white blood cells are made
in the bone marrow
so right away that steers you to the
bones
so you need to get rid of all the bad
stuff so you can absorb the good stuff
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils or glutens no wheat nobody Ryan
oats no buckwheat
um
and then uh I want you to take the
healthy brain and heart pack how they're
being a heart pack
um uh see here do we know how much this
person weighs
we don't so let's go with 100 pounds per
100 pounds of body weight one healthy
branded heart pack for 100 pounds of
body weight if they only weigh 100 and
510 pounds be a half a dose everything
twice a day if you weigh 150 or more
they need two now they're being heart
patch a month if they weigh 300 pounds
or more they need three Health abandon
hard packs a month and so on and then uh
for the bone marrow okay and the bone
cortex itself you need per 100 pounds of
body weight one bottle of the MSM so you
take say three twice a day per 100
pounds of body weight that's going to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae bone makes your bone itself
and the bone marrow or the white blood
cells and the red blood cells and the
antibodies and the platelets are made
your bone marrow one of the most
important tissues in your body
the odds are you will never see your
bone marrow
the ads are you will never see your own
bone marrow but is one of the most
important tissues in your body because
it makes red blood cells it makes white
blood cells it makes platelets I mean if
you just get a little Nick from a flower
Thorn okay
you'll bleed to death if you don't have
platelets so your bone marrow is very
very important there okay and so that's
what that that's where you make your
white blood cells is in your bone marrow
so you got to go there and then don't
forget
the collagen peptides uh scuba that
except for for 100 pounds of body weight
I'd go with a scoop for breakfast drink
scoop for dinner drink that'll be two
canisters a month and need the
um Beyond Osteo FX a scuba that of
breakfast with that dinner drink and
then don't forget the vitamin D3 even if
you live in a sunny place people say why
I live in Hawaii well how much time do
you spend out at the beach well you know
okay and so when you go to the beach you
take a
umbrella oh yeah sit in the shape we
don't sit out in the sun you know only
visitors sit out in the sun okay well
there you go you eat the vitamin D3 if
you're not sitting out in the sun and so
these are basic things that kids get
taught in sixth grade science but by the
time they're 18 years old they kind of
forget it
um they want to go with the good tasting
stuffs that makes them feel better for
at least a few minutes anyway
well I know as I'm driving around here
in Southern California and I see people
walking and jogging with umbrellas
that's like I would love to be out in
the sun just soaking up that Ray and the
nice thing about it that I've noticed Dr
Wallach since taking the 90 essential
nutrients with the essential fatty acids
and the collagen I can be out in the sun
much longer without going crispy
so correct I think that is that's just
another bonus
um that comes from giving your body what
it needs
and Don so don put in the comments here
he said one of my hotel general managers
was a uh was in the U.S Navy and told me
that when he was in the service the
ships Cooks were only allowed to use
white pepper
so Bravo on that one because that's
that's the only pepper I use
um and it still gives good flavor
now Dr wellick somebody is talking about
the books and wanting to know you know
the your books they can be found on our
website askdoglive.com we have many of
your popular books there just click on
Dr wallach's books and if you don't find
it there you can always go to
drjwalik.com which is Dr wallach's
website and find all of his Publications
there all of the CDs all the books all
the DVDs that are offered through
Wellness Publications so we want to make
sure that everybody has information and
access to the information
about
this valuable information that Dr
Wallach has put together through his
Decades of research well thank you back
and I want to add a little alert here
um we do have four new books in a 10 CD
set coming out
and and the cost of printing today is
like 25 more than it was three years ago
and 50 more than it was 10 years ago and
so
we're going to have to raise the prices
on all the books so if you've been
thinking about buying a book or two
don't forget you get a big discount if
you buy 10 of any one title and then
you're going to pay the current prices
if you buy them now if you wait until
the new price list comes out oh you say
oh God I should have bought them two
weeks ago and so be thinking about that
you know talk to whoever you need to in
your family and so forth get together
and
um at the very least at the very least
you want to get rarest man insurers
let's say doctor it's all in your head
Dead Doctors Don't Lie the truth about
nutrition
um epigenetics immortality get hold of
those books and you can add 25 to 50
Health years of your life just by adding
that information from those books and
CDs that come along with them to
to your lifestyle
I mean I've been doing this for 75 years
now most people think I'm in my 50s and
60s because my energy levels and all
that kind of stuff
and
I started taking all this stuff when I
was nine I started taking this 79 75
years ago
okay and so so pretty soon I'll be 84.
and I've only been on prescription drugs
three days out of my life and that was
um a long time ago
um when I uh had infections okay for
falling at up in Canada I fell in the
construction ditch we had been going
down that path forever
um in Canada because at night after a
meeting in Canada and we're walking down
this path to go to the parking lot and
the people who had used a backhoe to dig
a trench through there and they didn't
put a fence around or any warning or
anything there's no lights and guess who
stepped in the hole me and of course I
was punctured by all this rebar and
everything got infection so I had IV
antibiotics for three days and that was
it other than that and it wasn't
yeah it wasn't just a little whole
doctor well like you I saw pictures you
were kind of shish kebabs yeah that's
true
I oh I can't imagine I can't imagine but
you made it through you have all of your
toes all of your feet all of your legs
um which they wanted to take those off
my legs and they said okay well we're
gonna have to give you IV antibiotics
and we can't guarantee that you'll live
I said well
I'd rather die with my legs on
then have you kill me taking my legs off
so you're not taking my legs off forget
that just give me the IV antibiotics in
three days time the infection was down
all the swelling was down and I was out
of there
and you have little
to muscle tone it's it's incredible Dr
Wallach after seeing all the pictures
and spending a little bit of time with
you and it's it's unbelievable
and I I know you contributed to
having the nutrition
on board already
and not just as a response to
getting oh yeah no I've been taken again
you know I was I was in my
uh gosh I had to be
in my 60s
now when that happened Dr Wallach that
was less than five years ago oh was it
was it less than five years ago that was
less than five years ago it was in my
late 70s yeah
yeah most people most people that age
would have died from that trauma as you
say I was just about by all that by all
that rebar and the infection was
horrible
and uh you know the doctors walk in the
wolf we got to cut those legs off
we're going there
yeah well I I'm glad
to go there that's for sure and you made
it through or able to continue this
message and just use that as proof that
it works
so Dr Wallach
yes ma'am Nancy has a question because
we were just now talking about bone
marrow okay and what are your thoughts
on bone marrow transplant
well there are times when that's
necessary
um when people have uh kind of radiation
poisoning or they've been starving and
your bone marrow is dead there's nothing
to revive because there's you know if
you just sort of give give your bone
marrow what it needs to revive and
there's no live bone marrow cells in
there because they took a biopsy there's
nothing alive in there that's when you
need a bone marrow transplant so there
are times when you have to do those
extreme things
but they're going to go by blood type
and all this kind of stuff and so
they're going to match your blood type
so your bone marrow is happy and but
then
they don't all do the same thing here's
where in addition to the bone marrow
transplant they need to jump on
the uh Hildebrand and heart pack the MSM
the collagen peptides Beyond Osteo
vitamin D3 they need to throw all that
stuff out at the same time to really
enhance and support that bone marrow
transplant because you want to take care
of that baby
well you most definitely do I mean your
your blood is manufactured in your bone
marrow if your bone marrow is not
healthy you're not going to have healthy
blood just as you mentioned so we
definitely want to make sure that we're
giving our body what it needs to be
healthy on a whole because that blood is
what circulates all the nutrition
throughout the body and if it's not
circulating and if it's not healthy
then there's there's no possible way to
have good health what about oxygen
well that has to be circulated through
that's right that has to be circulated
through the blood too and if that
circulation is not helping or not going
through the body
then you're not getting the oxygen
either
so
it's amazing how everything is not a
part everything is a whole it all works
together and you start taking Parts out
then the whole starts to decline as well
now try driving your car without a fuel
pump
I've had my fuel pump go out before and
it does not does not go
So and I've had the power steering pump
go out and that made it very hard to
steer so think about it you get
arthritis and your bones and joints that
makes it hard to move
you can still do it
but not with any type of ease or comfort
so let's just be proactive and we can
even be reactive
and get results I was reactive although
I thought I was being proactive
what I was doing because what was taught
by
people that we trusted was incorrect
information
and here we're used giving information
that isn't taught on any type of federal
or government level
yet
so Dr Wallach let's go to a hand that is
up and Deborah let me go ahead and ask
you to unmute
and welcome to ask.line hello hello doc
Wallach hello how can we help you
um I have a client who has had a heart
transplant a few years ago and uh they
won't let her go on the full 90 because
they don't they're very protective of
thinking that she's going to have some
kind of reaction that's going to cause
some kind of problems because they're
trying you know they got her on meds to
keep her immune system kind of low so
she doesn't reject the heart so I'd like
some input about that and now she has
low iron and uh they're talking about
giving her iron infusions
okay well there's several things going
on here number one she needs to stay
away from all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat by Ryan oats no sugar
no buckwheat all that's got to go to
make sure she can absorb nutrients right
and that's not taking anything special
it's just getting rid of the bathtub
then
um Everybody Needs 90 essential
nutrients that's that's a given
and so they can't say you can't have 90
essential nutrients because that's the
the good Lord made us with all our
equipment requiring those nutrients
right so she needs the 90 cents of
nutrients
and then of course the bone marrow
requires
um about a dozen different secret sauces
and so here's where again
the
um
which they say here's where the the
Health abandoned heart pack come in you
need all these nutrients to make the
bone marrow happy and again don't forget
to MSM don't forget the collagen
peptides don't forget Beyond Osteo don't
forget the vitamin D3 and
um this is kind of like Grandma's old
bone broth
I know if you're old enough to remember
Grandma making bone broth it's you know
take the chicken bones and beef bones
and ribs and stuff like that and put
them in some vinegar and let them simmer
on the wood stove overnight and then we
would all fight to see who's gonna get
that bone broth because it would rebuild
your bones
okay well that was too difficult to
contemplate doing as a sales product for
for an international company so we came
out with the collagen peptides which is
bone broth from fish poultry sheep and
beef all in one product and so we've
sort of ramped up on Grandma's recipe
and that's that's what it's far it's
replacing bone broth and so it doesn't
hurt for this person to ask another
doctor say hey is there any reason why I
can't have you know I had a heart
transplant is there any reason why I
can't have vitamins and minerals
is a supplement okay
um you know I'm a little anemic and all
this kind of stuff I don't I I need
something to help me here but also they
need to participate by getting rid of
the bad stuff including gluten and the
and the buckwheat
stuff okay which is the Faygo Sirens
okay
all that's got to go
and um because they cause and contribute
to big big problems
so I hope that helps you I don't know
yeah because I can't say yes or no
because she's not my patient okay but
she does need these things and so if
she's not getting them from her food
she's getting clinical problems then she
needs to ask you know another doctor
um
in her area
um is it okay if I take some bottoms and
minerals
um you know I've got this problem this
problem this problem and just eating
well for the last six months hasn't
helped me as yet slowly getting worse I
need to take somebody's minerals and my
doctor says don't take Autumn's minerals
so what do you think and so you know
kind of have her go that way okay okay
all right thank you yeah let us know
what happens and we'll be happy to
everyone again a three-way with her on
or if you want to get her doctor on her
here well we'll talk to her doctor
okay
that'll be fun right
thank you thank you doc
all right thank you Deborah great
question which then addressed a question
that somebody else had in the comments
about buckwheat so I hope he was able to
listen and hear that answer as well now
Dr Wallach
Nancy brings up the fact that nobody has
brought up Als in a while okay and it
it's possible that people don't bring it
up because they've been told that it is
incurable
so what are your comments on ALS
okay amalotrophic lateral sclerosis of
course
um has to do with
um which I say it goes along with
um let's see here
Parkinson's disease it goes along with
Alzheimer's disease it goes along uh
with Tourette's Syndrome it goes along
with Ms it goes along with all those
things and these are all nutritional
deficiencies including ALS and so people
with ALS need to get rid of all the bad
foods
no no gluten no we've been around oats
no buckwheat okay no phagopyries and
then need to take three eggs twice a day
after adults three eggs twice a day with
coffee yolks
and then of course they need to help the
brain and heart pack
they need a collagen peptides
uh they need to take the
um let's see here
I also have them take the synaptives
three of those twice a day and have them
take the memory of x three of those
twice today
and that's kind of where I would start
what about so the ALS really affects the
the sheath my myelin sheath on the
nerves and I know our ultimate niacin
has ingredients in it that help to
promote the health of that sheath okay
well go for the ultimate knives and also
can hurt I take that I take one of those
at breakfast one dinner time I take two
I get on that that um see I'm I'm
opposite I have to take two at a time or
I get a hot flash and flush and and go
ahead share with us a little bit what
that is if you would
well it's a it's a sudden dilation of
your blood vessels caused by the niacin
the blood vessel suddenly dilate and you
just get this hot flash okay and so
because the blood is Flowing right
that's correct
isn't that what we wanted to do that's
correct
and so I don't know I don't mind a mild
one but I don't want a hot flash it puts
me out of business I mean it was just
yeah you're so so disruptive you just
can't I'm sorry I'll be back in 15
minutes kind of thing
well and the nice thing about it though
Dr Wallach is it doesn't last very long
and it is about 15-20 minutes for most
people and something that you can do is
drink extra water
make sure that you're staying hydrated
and you think about it when you're
taking the health you're being a heart
pack you're taking
215 separate nutrients and then I throw
in you you know you visit us you've seen
the table with all my supplements on it
I have 55 bottles on the table so I take
the 215 nutrients plus my 55 additional
supplements on top of that so I'm taking
about 270 different nutrients
okay twice a day that's twice a day and
so
yeah
what can I say it's one of those things
where
you put your
priorities where they're at well my
priorities are to live to be at least a
minimum of 200 but I think 400 600 is
even better but a minimum of 200 is
about right
and so we have so many people to help so
many people that need information and
they're suffering terribly from simple
things that we can pass on information
to them and help them get through this
uh without you know a catastrophe and so
you have to be personally responsible
and take care of yourself so yeah if
you're 200 years old people got to
listen to you when it comes to aging if
you you know if you're you know in the
emergency room dying and you're 40
nobody's going to listen to you about
health
that's true I know the first time I saw
that table Dr Wally
it's like it's a it's a two by five
table folks
and
he's got a little bit of space where he
lines up his bottles
and three feet of that one by three
minimum
is packed full
of the supplements he is a product of
the product and now that's not the 90
essential nutrients those are my ads
those are special sauces that's right
secret sauces special sauces yep
yeah and then on the counter right there
in front of the refrigerator you got
your Tangy Tangerine your Osteo effects
and your collagen peptides so and then
the canister of the rebound I like the
canister of the rebound because it does
have less sugar and many people ask well
if Doc's not for carbonation why do they
make a carbonated drink and folks
we have to meet people where they're at
when people are out there buying hand
over fist canned drinks
that provide
artificial energy
and it's it's from sugar and caffeine
which creates a
spike in their blood sugar
and then a drop
you've got to meet people where they're
at we got to put something in a can like
what they've been wanting to buy
so that they'll want to buy it also and
unfortunately carbonation helps to
satisfy another one of those reasons
people buy that drink let me add a piece
of your answer to everybody's heard Red
Bull
that is the most best-selling
what should I say power
drink Red Bull
and one of the co-founders of the Red
Bull company who manufactured it died
about two weeks ago they haven't
released his cause of death yet I'm very
very interested in his car it was sudden
he was just
he just died in his sleep one night and
no previous illnesses or anything and he
had bragged for many years and I had
gone to several other meetings and he'd
bragged for many years that he's
drinking 10 cans of Red Bull every day
for 25 years it's all carbonated right
and um so I finally got digging into
what is Red Bull
well it's caffeine it's sugar
um it is uh let's see here it has all
the B vitamins in it
all the B vitamins and it does have one
mineral magnesium
it doesn't have 60 minerals in it
okay our rebound has 75 minerals
including the 60 essential minerals
including magnesium
okay yeah and so
um Red Bull is not a complete supplement
where our rebound is a complete
supplement except for essential fatty
acids
okay it has all 90 essential nutrients
except for the essential fatty acids
and so that's that's a big difference
between a high sugar high caffeine one
mineral
drink carb which is carbonated the Red
Bull and one of the co-founders died I
think he is
75 or 78 somewhere in there
um suddenly just went to sleep that
night didn't wake up in the morning
and so
um you know and I'm sure he was a very
nice man
and so it's one of those things where uh
you have to kind of look and say okay do
I want to go that direction or do I want
to take the the rebound and if I like
canned and drinks I've just popped the
top like while it does and leave it off
the ass of the carbonation at night and
drink it flat and all the bubbly's gone
in the morning
I like to drink it with a banana
mix it all up
and it's just so good
I love it but not the can I use the
powder in the canister
um so that I'm not getting all of that
Sugar because sugar creates FAT it's not
fat that creates FAT folks sugar creates
FAT
so we stay away from sugar we don't have
that high blood sugar Spike and drop
what
and mineral deficiencies cause fat
and mineral to fish well yes because
mineral deficiencies your body thinks
it's starving so it's going to hold on
to everything that it does get
and you're going to eat more and more
and more which is Aika you know you'll
eat 10 meals a day instead of three
well uh you know what study that you
mentioned that Dr Wallach
there was a time in my largest moments
where they were saying to eat six small
meals a day
so I was eating those six small meals a
day
I calculated it one day my small meals
were like 2 400 calories
each and very little nutrition no not
each
not each but twice the amount that what
I should have been eating if going by a
1200 calorie diet
to lose weight which
I I'm kind of losing some trust no I did
I did lose a lot of trust in their
studies because none of them were
working for me and I got on your program
my first three months I lost 20 pounds I
wasn't even trying and it's because I
was giving the body those minerals the
body no longer felt like it was in
Starvation mode and it started releasing
and now I'm down 105 pounds so I think
it works
I do
thank you thank you for being on the
radio for all these years Dr Wallach
and talking to the air because I my ears
heard that air and I greatly appreciate
it let's go to Yvonne who has her hand
up patiently
Yvonne go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with Dr Wallach hi you
caught me
um I needed about a two minute warning
give me a second
unfortunately I can't say Yvonne you're
up next in two minutes oh darling but
there you are beautiful hey hi doc good
morning good to see you again
um so I have a 67 year old she's 1 30.
uh pounds uh she's developed over the
last I think six plus years basically
she describes it as hardening from the
inside out she has a calcium very very
large calcium
um cutaneous you know like
um inner wrist uh she's got some
calcifications in the lungs in the
kidneys
her skin is extremely tight and shiny
they have decided that she has
Scleroderma how can we help her and
what's going on is it a calcium issue is
it a deficiency
okay well scleroderma is a nutritional
deficiency
it's actually like osteoporosis of the
skin
wow okay Derma is skin yeah sclera is
scarring okay Scleroderma so she needs
to get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils or
gluten so we've around those so sugar no
carbonated drinks of any kind
um uh no buckwheat and then I want her
to
um have uh see here she weighed
130. she's still oh yeah actually 130
pounds so she she needs to I since she
has Scleroderma and it can be a lead to
fatal things so she needs to get two
healthy brain and heart pasture months
to how they're abandoned heart faction
month a photo or something twice a day I
want to get two bottles a month for MSM
so you could take three of breakfast
three lunch three dinner time she needs
um let's see here two canisters of the
collagen peptides so you could take a
scoop of that with a breakfast drink a
scoop it out of their evening drink I
want her also to take our vitamin D3
through those twice a day I also want
her to have uh let's see here
Hair Skin and Nails I'm going to get two
bottles a month of Hair Skin and nails
so she could take um
three of those I'd have her take three
three times a day she has scleroderm I
never take three three times a day this
of the Hair Skin and nails
and let's see here
um
I think that's going to cover the
waterfront
it's going to cover the Waterfront
um
and again she's going to stay away from
all the bad stuff so you can maximize
absorption of all these things
and let's see here Becca did I miss
anything
you muted I think you got it I think you
got it DOC okay we just want to make
sure we're supporting the connective
tissue and have all those those
co-factors so that the calcium could
actually utilized where it's needed
so no extra well you're gonna have EFA
since you said healthy brain and extra
efas yeah two healthy Brandon hard packs
so she'll be able to take three efas and
threefa pluses twice a day and why the
um D3 that sounds like the capsules can
I give her the the um
the Spritz
the citrity
oh yeah yeah
anything works as long as D3 because
this is where
um this is how you help your body absorb
particularly calcium okay and put it in
all the right places including the bones
in the skin and cartilage and ligaments
and all those connective tissue
um you need that vitamin D3
and again people knew in the old days
that if you didn't have sunlight you'd
get trouble you get rickets kids would
get rickets if they didn't have the
sunlight
uh and of course Ricketts it was a big
big big deal uh when suddenly
um they were burning coal uh in big
cities and when they're burning coal you
know to make electricity and stuff like
that uh it clouded out the Sun and and
Ricketts went crazy uh in the big cities
uh because of that
and Doc real quick she uh questioned um
when I gave her some stuff she said well
I have to have you know K2 with my D3
but there were no minerals in her D3 and
K2
um can you can you talk on that
well if she wants to get a K2 just add
it to
uh R's don't replace anything because
her K2 only has K2 yeah
she's gonna give up five nutrients to
take one no it doesn't make sense all
right good approach yeah
thank you so much yeah
sorry doc no no go ahead Yvonne don't go
anywhere Dr Wallach
I love the fact that we have
practitioners
that are so instrumental in making sure
that your programs and supplements are
being utilized within their practices
and Yvonne's one of them I just love her
to death and she brought up a very good
point in regards to B vitamins because I
had seen some articles recently about B
vitamins and one of them talking about
synthetic B vitamins being toxic to our
bodies
and so I went looking up that form of B
in our supplements and we didn't have it
I was so so excited we had the the
natural non-synthetic form of B vitamins
which when you look at Red Bull
it's got synthetic B vitamins not
natural so thank you so much for
reminding me of that Yvonne absolutely
and I think that's one thing that we all
hear need to remember when you are
questioned with
um something like that well my doctor
says remember and and Doc help us out
here something like 99.9 of all of these
research articles are on synthetic
nutrients made in a laboratory not plant
food so you have to you know educate
yourself educate your um your customers
and your family and you will make a an
even bigger difference
yeah and of course doctors don't get
much training for nutrition except if
salesmen come by and they give them a
sample or something like that
um
a sixth grader can know more about
nutrition their doctor does the doctor
all they say is just eat well you get
everything you need that's an absolutely
false statement every time a doctor
should say that they should spend 10
years in jail
oh just eat while you get everything you
need that's not possibly true it's not
possible to be true
not at all and one more thing Yvonne
thank you so much for your services I
know that you did serve in our Armed
Forces as well thank you
absolutely what branch of the service to
use all right I was in the Navy uh also
served with the Marines and
um worked in the dental and the medical
field
well thank you so much God bless you for
your service
hey thank you for your book doc that's
how I got introduced to you
um when I was reading the um Doctors
Don't Lie oh no no no the big one the
one that cost me uh the price of a small
car okay yeah it's a 25 000 for one yes
yes
I'm still reading it I'm about a part of
it okay I have a good I have good news
about that uh that book The diseases
exotic animals was my twenty thousand
autopsies okay twenty thousand options
to autops are represented in that book
and it was a 10-year study 25 million
dollar study and proved there were no
genetically transmitted diseases there's
no autoimmune diseases and of course we
sold out like in 90 days sold out
and of course the replacement part
because the average person's not going
to spend 25 000 is epigenetics okay it's
kind of a summary of that book okay
thank you okay is is a summary of it now
the good news is
um we have the book The diseases of God
again it was a 25 000 book hit the
printers right now
and they're printing
each chapter is going to be a book
oh so you can buy the books chat the
book The chapter at a time okay and so
I'm very excited about that and this is
going to go very quickly because of all
the equipment we have now with all the
computers and this that and the other
and so we're going to buzz through this
and so it's gonna be made available here
pretty soon and
it's going to floor people it's going to
freak people out will that be marketed
to veterinarians or two no no to humans
that relates to disease nutrition how it
relates to human disease
fantastic
fantastic I know sometimes people ask me
why are you reading that you know they
don't they don't understand what you did
well not only that
um most of the research and nutrition
for humans is done in rabbits and mice
and guinea pigs it's all done in animals
and pigs and calves and horses yes and
so forth it's not done in people because
you have to kill them at the end of the
study
to do all all the the microscopic stuff
and chemistry and so forth and so that
wouldn't work unless you're a Nazi okay
well I hope you'll be promoting that
strongly oh yeah as soon as as soon as
the first
um
um Supply comes off the printers uh we
will be punching that hard because
everybody will be everybody will be able
to afford it
Becca can I get a um can you help me get
a signed copy
I can help to get a signed copy
absolutely
all right thanks so much for your
service we love you thank you so much
for your service God bless you thank you
thank you Yvonne thank you you and your
team do
Navy and the Marines holy moly
she's she's a Powerhouse doc well she's
a Powerhouse we have a lot of
powerhouses in our young family what
state does she live in now she's in our
state she's in California
just farther north
and
yeah so
Dr walk we have ah there's so many
things I want to talk about and we're
almost out of time okay so we only have
10 more minutes well you have two hours
of radio coming up this afternoon
yes so we have Dead Doctors Don't Lie
that is aired on ksco 1080 am and if you
go to their website ksco
.com and then click on k-o-m-y or do a
search better yet do a search for Dead
Doctors Don't Lie it will give you the
information that you need in order to
jump on and have a whole nother hour of
being able to ask Dr Wallach questions
in regards to your health they're on the
air and folks don't be shy
somebody else out there is experiencing
the same thing that you are experiencing
and they may be listening to that
syndicated program and because of your
question you could be also helping them
change their life and create a better
health Journey for them as well so we
encourage you to jump on to Dr wallach's
radio programs also Monday through
Friday from 12 to 1 p.m Pacific time
and then I apologize I don't know all of
the information for the let's play
doctor
um because that is that's another
affiliation that I'm not part of but I
love KSC yeah that's from uh one to two
but uh both those stations are uh AM
radio and
um been doing that for over 32 years
32 years that's called Longevity doctor
that's like stick-to-dickness
so stick-to-itiveness and for those of
you who are on the zoom with us Ruth
Allen just put the information in the
chat on how you can plug in and make a
phone call and ask Dr Wallach on his
program
um I'm honored to be on with you on
Wednesdays on that program yeah you're a
co-host that's awesome yes I think it's
absolutely fabulous and I want to know
where people are joining us in from and
I asked that question in the chat doctor
well like and I know for a fact we have
people in West Virginia and Virginia and
South Carolina North Carolina Utah
Washington California Pennsylvania
um of course
California I think I said that already
we also have South Africa Dr Wallach
um outside of Johannesburg
[Music]
yes thank you very much
yeah I'm gonna learn it I really am I I
promise Albert I'm gonna learn it
um
and I love the fact that we are reaching
around the world we've got the UK
um yes Blue Ridge Virginia I I think
it's fabulous Dr Wallach that and more
people are plugging in here Sacramento
California
uh Los Angeles I know Angelica's in the
Los Angeles area it's just absolutely
fantastic and if you are watching this
program because somebody referred you to
it we hope that you did get information
that is beneficial for you in helping
you reach your health Journeys and
welcome Phoenix Arizona and Oregon
awesome they keep keep them coming keep
them coming yeah I'm sure license is a
physician in Oregon naturopathic
physician
so your licensed as a naturopathic
physician in Oregon and in California
that's correct yep absolutely and of
course
you've been a veterinarian around the
world
yes and people people forget Dr Wallach
two beers in South Africa
two years in South Africa but
vertebrates we are a vertebrate we're a
mammal with a backbone
and vertebrates have like all of the
different functions that we do yes Rhino
Express
there's only 350 left back then now
there's 21 000 so I'm very proud of that
absolutely
absolutely and that's that's like a
little Adventure book for kids so if you
have a
um
not too young of a reader but if you
have a young reader or somebody that's
into adventure books that would be a
great stocking stuffer
for your loved ones whether nieces
nephews children grandchildren the
neighbor kid
go to drjwalik.com and you'll be able to
find a rhino Express there
and
goodness what else so we did have a
question in regards to sugar
Dr Wallach
well sugar sugar in small amounts is a
good fuel
that's all it is it's a fuel that you
burn it and you keep your calories going
so your various functions and organs can
do their job as well as move your
muscles and move from here to there and
so sugar in modest Amounts is not a bad
thing but like all things even oxygen
and too much
uh you know he rushed inside when you
have too much oxygen okay things
oxidized and they turn into bad things
they turn into cancer and so you have to
make sure uh even water you drown if you
have too much water water is important
for hydration but if you take too much
water you can dilute your nutrients over
a long period of time and and get
nutritional deficiencies if you drink
too much water but also
um you can drown if you drink too much
water okay and so
um it's one of those things where uh you
know in this co-founder of Red Bull died
um we're they haven't released his cause
of death yet I don't know if they have
asked the coroner not to do that or or
why but that's been two weeks they
should know by now what he died from and
um
and keep looking but I don't find it
being I keep asking Siri you know what
did he die from and this is a cause of
death not yet posted okay so we shall
see eventually
um we have to wait till all those
doctors die
well goodness
that's not very nice start your wallet
well I said wait we don't want to wish
we don't want to wish death on anybody
even though it's I mean eventually all
of us are Gonna Leave This Life as We
Know It
but to to wish it on anybody we don't
want to do that and we want to promote I
know you're not wishing but you're just
waiting but so
Nancy Nancy has a cute little story that
she put in
um in the chat and she said I quit sugar
intake at 29 years old and I know she's
a few few years beyond that and she said
that at night she dreamed of eating
cheesecake and clustered eclairs for two
straight weeks and then she was free of
any interest in Suites ever again so she
went through that detoxification stage
folks and if you plug through push
through and especially if you're giving
your body the 90 essential nutrients
you will get through it and with the 90
essential nutrients DACA didn't take
very long I did not have those cravings
for those sweet things anymore
I didn't I still don't and
yeah I don't have any Cravings that's
really emotional stuff
yeah given three emotional stuff and
through you know women men too they go
through hormonals changes yeah
I I think that we all do
and I'm no I'm not going to ask you doc
I'm just going to tell you you do
um
and when your body is neutrified you
don't have those swings
and I'm gonna get my co-hosts on here
with me because they have done such a
great job making sure that the chat is
running smooth making sure that
everybody that has their camera on is
doing what they're supposed to do and
just answering questions in the chat I
absolutely love and appreciate them and
Heather Ruth Ellen janty Dr Wallach
thank you so much for being part of ask
doc live thank you we love you another
week another week of being able to
provide information that people aren't
going to get in other places
so share it share it share it share it
share it with everyone you know
um do a search or critical Health News
YouTube page has all of our replays also
so you can go through there look at the
different topics that we offer also on
the critical Health
news.com website look at the different
topics you will I know think of somebody
I was like oh I know that person that's
suffering from that I know that person
that's dealing with that share that
video with them make sure that they at
least have the opportunity to get
information
that could change their lives and help
them find a new health Journey that they
will be happier with
so on behalf of ass talk live my name is
Rebecca dukes and we appreciate you
spending this time with us
on a stock live bye for now bye-bye love
you
bye-bye